five days ago the nfc championship game
ended with one of the worst non-calls in
a postseason game that we can ever
remember the saints had the ball
deep in l.a rams territory was third
down and tommy lee lewis was just wiped
out by nikhil roby-coleman should have
been first in goal for the saints at
about the five-yard line with a minute
49 to play and the rams having one
timeout and the saints in position to
run the clock down kick a field goal and
give the rams very very limited time on
the clock to try to match it or beat it
that has been one of the biggest
controversies of the week there have
been developments every day and through
it all the commissioner has been
silent ben watson one of the most
respected players in the national
football league a member of the new
orleans saints posted this statement
yesterday on twitter commissioner
goodell we all realized that football
isn't a perfect game played coached and
officiated by imperfect people what
occurred last sunday in new orleans
though was outside of that expected and
accepted norm your continued silence on
this matter is unbecoming of the
position you hold detrimental to the
integrity of the game and disrespectful
and dismissive to football fans
everywhere from the locker room to park
avenue accountability is what makes our
league great lead by example
we are waiting
ben watson saints tight end saying what
a lot of saints fans and other fans
media and observers are thinking where
is roger goodell tom kern who's going to
join us coming up here in about 10
minutes talk patriots he calls roger
goodell the highest paid pin cushion in
the world because goodell is there to
take the flack that otherwise would go
to the owners in this case though it's a
siege mentality again at 345 park avenue
the kind of thing we first saw with the
ray rice case back in 2014 so the
commissioner who spoke somewhat
extensively in the rice case he had that
press conference and maybe didn't go all
that well and i think they've realized
you know what
there's a chance that whatever he says
may make it worse so let's just have him
say nothing and there is a sensitivity
the way i understand it there was a
willingness on sunday night to come out
and acknowledge the error and privately
they've admitted it privately the the
nfl has communicated to the saints that
yes they screwed it up
it's one thing to admit it privately
it's another thing to admit it publicly
because then you admit it publicly and
what happens the rams are delegitimized
as super bowl participants so there was
a thought at one point they were going
to mention in this statement well we got
the non-call
wrong as it relates to past interference
but we also missed a face mask that was
committed against jared goff in the
prior drive so it kind of evens out they
decided not to do that they've just
decided to do nothing now they they
leaked to some reporters the idea that
that there would be potential solutions
via expansion of replay review but in
the aftermath of that you had the people
on the bunch of people on the record
connected to the league including
competition committee chairman rich
mckay saying
that won't work
so
where are we five days later we're
nowhere we're back to where we started
and i think the league at this point
just hopes it all goes away that they
get a hard reset going into super bowl
week but the problem is
one of the super bowl contenders is the
team that benefited from that bad
non-call so
whenever the commissioner has his press
conference it used to be on friday when
maximum media was in the super bowl city
they have now moved it back to wednesday
they've done that for several years now
and and the stated reason is they don't
want the commissioners press conference
to overshadow the the run up to the
super bowl the reality is you've got far
fewer people in the media
who are there
earlier in the week so wednesday at 1 pm
eastern is when the commissioner will be
speaking and what someone needs to do
and this is not an easy thing to do
i made the analogy earlier in the
program to the one ring and i know
that's an extremely nerdy reference and
i apologize in advance but let me tell
you when you get that one ring in your
hand and you're standing in mount doom
over the fires and you got to throw it
in there and destroy it right good luck
doing it because when you get that
microphone in your hand at the
commissioner's press conference
even if you have it scripted out a very
concise and narrow question that puts
the commissioner on the spot puts him in
a position where all he can say is yes
or no
you're gonna end up instead asking a
question with a 45 second preamble that
has five parts to it because you got
that microphone in your hand and the
last thing you're doing is throwing that
thing into the fires of mount doom and
i've been there i can relate and every
year it happens so
someone in that if if they if they
happen to give the microphone to someone
that that may ask the question because
let me tell you that microphone is going
to get selectively passed around to
people who will never ask the question
if it ends up in the hands of someone
who may ask the question we'll see if if
that person manages to pull the sword
out of the stone and ask the direct
question and get a direct answer a
non-evasive answer a real answer an
honest answer about whether or not there
was an error and what the league will do
moving forward to improve the situation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports